hey Americans just your neighborhood
friendly Canadian here with a bit of
advice about how you can deal with your
upcoming election without developing an
ulcer now I know some of you are saying
that you'll move to Canada if Donald
Trump becomes your president please
don't see Canadians are heading to the
polls next week on October 19th and
we're scared list that our prime
minister will be reelected why because
the Conservative Party leaders Stephen
Harper the biggest issue this election
isn't the recession it isn't about over
a thousand missing and murdered Native
women hell it's not even about Canada's
increased military aggression abroad
it's about Canadian Muslim women and
what they wear in particular than the
cob the Islamic covering that only
reveals the eyes our prime minister has
said he'll fight a recent federal court
decision to allow Muslim women to wear
the niqab at their Canadian citizenship
ceremony yeah Stephen Harper wants to
ban Canadian Muslim women from
practicing their newly attained rights
and freedoms asked Canadians logic
sounds logical and apparently he's not
alone according to one recent poll 82%
of Canadians actually agree with
Harper's position but the hysteria
doesn't match up to the reality only two
percent of Canadians and women actually
wear the niqab but that hasn't stopped
the Conservatives from milking and
timeless and sentiments and time with
some fears for every last vote that it
can get them
they've even pledged a tip line that
allows Canadians to call on other
Canadians that they suspect of engaging
in quote barbaric cultural practices and
no voting for Stephen Harper doesn't
count but this isn't just an election
issue this is how this Prime Minister
has run and divided this country for
almost 10 years almost 1 million
Canadians with dual citizenship have
officially become second-class citizens
in June a new law was introduced that
allows the Canadian government to strip
any Canadian with dual citizenship
convicted of terrorism of
their Canadian citizenship even if
you're born in Canada for perspective if
you commit treason in the United States
you still get to be a US citizen and of
course then there are just hearing
refugees after coming under fire for not
taking in any Syrian refugees when the
government did decide to welcome some
into the country it was revealed that
Harper was again up to no good
according to a recent Globe and Mail
reports the Prime Minister's Office was
personally going through Syrian refugee
applications not the Citizenship and
Immigration Office Syrian refugees were
being vetted on the basis of religion
meaning Christian Syrian refugees were
preferable to those Muslim refugees it
was even said that the move is motivated
by a drive for votes Christian Syrian
refugees would be more easily accepted
into established Canadian communities
bringing in more votes for Harper so
yeah Americans we have universal health
care we're polite and we say sorry weird
but we're not the haven of sensibility
you all seem to think we still are
because the biggest election we've had
in years could be determined by how many
Canadians are bigoted against other
fellow Canadians kind of like your
Republican primaries and is not races by
the Canadian government up until 1996
supported Native education by sending
young Native children to church run